TO SEE JOSH MORRISSEY AND NATE
SCHMIDT DE-CLOYIT
OF A KNUCKLER IN ON BINNINGTON
AND MAKES THE GLOVE GRAB TO THE
BACKHAND, SAVE MADE THE SAVE AN
REBOUND CHOPPED AWAY FROM THE P!
KYLE CONNOR SHORT SIDE O THE SI
AND GETTITI AT.
HELLEBUYCK DOWN ON HIS KNEES AND
HE DISHES IT OFFER,EROUS, UNDER
MINUTES IN THE P FORCOACH
LATE BOBBY BELOW.G FORWARD TO
RUSH BECAUSE THEY'RE PLAYING
CONNECTED AS A GROUP OF FIVE
>> Dennis: STANLEY HAMMERS ONE
FROM THE BLUE LINE, THAT WENT
SCORES!
[ Horn ].
[  TIME YOU'LL
SEE THIS GOAL.
THIS WILL BE R ZONE.
BINNINGTON COMES OUT TO PLAY IT.
WHERE IS IT?
THEY BANG AWAY AT  PLAY STAYS A.
THEIR GAME, NO DOUBT ABOUT  RAC.
SENDS IT OFIZE.
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT BLAKE
WHEELER BEING AROUND A LOT OF
THE ACTION GENERATED RIGHT TIMEE
WISDOM WORK AND IT'S RIGHT BACK
UP THE ICE NOW FOR BUCHNEVICH.
OUTSIDE, INSIDE, BACK TOINTO
THE GAME TONIGHT.
THIS WAS A WELL PLAYED  AT THE
LINE, SLAPSHOT, SAVE, REBOUORD.
THIS YEAR, THE LOSS IN
MINNESOTA, LOSS IN SAN JOSE IT
BEHIND HIS OWN NET AS THE OFF.
PARAYKO, BEING WATCHED BY
SCHEIFELE AND SCHEIFELE WILL
CHASE HIM BACK OUT TO  FOR KYRO.
KYROU CARRIES IN, SHOT, RIGHT A
MINUTE
>> Dennis: RYAN O'REILLY NEX IN.
>> Kevin: WHAT A BACKHAND